well he claimed he could cure a child's
cancer according to one father tonight
never before heard allegations against
accused sex predator Nathan chasing
horse 8 news now investigator Vanessa
Murphy has this story you'll only see
here
we were devastated
I think I just went into
um
fight mode Jason Smith says he tried to
do everything he could to save his son
we have to do what we have to do to try
to get him better at just 13 years old a
diagnosis of leukemia I just remember
hearing those words and then having to
look at
um his mom and him and and they broke
down justice Smith Hilton was a hockey
player a champion dancer at Powell's and
from birth he had been raised in his
native culture through teachings and
ceremony his energy was pure he was
beautiful he says justice underwent
chemotherapy for 18 months and while it
appeared to be helping it also caused
complications he struggled the family
then turned to Nathan chasing horse an
actor from the movie Dances with Wolves
who claims he's a medicine man we were
under the impression that this man could
save our son they drove from the Toronto
area where they lived to Las Vegas in
early 2020. he says he gave chasing
horse and his several wives gifts and
food and then chasing horse performed
what's referred to as a dark room
ceremony to us it was very powerful and
how was Justin just feeling after that
first ceremony he was um in high hopes
he was excited he was looking forward to
the future he says they later learned
chasing horse would want them to return
for three more phases of his so-called
treatment which included herbal drinks
what he claimed were natural antibiotics
and Phoenix Tears which he claimed were
the highest form of cannabis to help
manage pain something like a doctor you
put your faith in when do you realize
things are not improving and you start
to question chasing horse it was
actually during the fourth phase he says
while Justice appeared to be
deteriorating chasing horse claimed it
was the cancer leaving his body and when
Jason questioned him he was shocked at
his answer he responded with a threat
and he said he was going to take the
cancer out of my son and put it in my
left testicle four months after the
family turned to chasing horse Justice
took his final breath it's devastating
um
to lose a child under those
circumstances
uh
there really is no words for it the
state of Nevada versus Nathan chasing
the horse in January of 2023 chasing
horse was arrested in Clark County for
sex crimes against children sex
trafficking and more now he also faces
federal charges there's a warrant in
Montana and another in Canada the 46
year old man is accused of victimizing
indigenous women and children for two
decades now Jason says he believes he
knows why his family may have been a
Target I think there was motive to kind
of Groom my daughters he says chasing
horse was never alone with his daughters
but he does recall chasing horse
disappearing for hours with his son at
least twice toward the end of the teen's
life it was questionable I'm not sure
what would happen on these trips he says
he believes chasing horse and his
alleged cult known as the circle
elated his family during the most
vulnerable time when people say
well if you knew then why would you you
know why would you be Associated well
you don't really know
um especially when you're
um your focus is on somebody like my son
uh with an illness when your focus is on
them 100 you don't see what's going on
around you do you believe Nathan Chase
and Morse is a medicine man no I don't
do you believe he's a predator yes I do
do you believe Nathan chasting horse is
a cult leader yes he says he believes
Nathan chasing horse should remain
Behind Bars and also be held accountable
for taking away his son's chance at life
do you feel like you paid the ultimate
price as a parent
yes yes
we did there's nothing worth more than
your loved ones right and especially
your children there's no price that you
can put on you know that kind of
connection that kind of love I yeah I
lost my best friend
Vanessa Murphy 8 News Now
Jason Smith estimates that he spent
twenty thousand dollars on the trips
back and forth from Canada to Southern
Nevada and that includes money he spent
on food and gifts for chasing horse and
his wives chasing horse was indicted by
a grand jury and expected back in court
next week